jetzt hat sich auch der papst zu wort
gemeldet und zwar mit bemerkenswerten
worten hat das bellen der nato an
russlands tür zu putins invasion in der
ukraine geführt mit dieser ja sehr
merkwürdigen aussage sorgt der papst
heute für aufsehen das bellen der nato
an russland tür also als ob der westen
der aggressor sei die wortwahl ist mehr
als erstaunlich und entspricht letztlich
genau der argumentation putins weiß gott
was er sich dabei gedacht hat wir gehen
zu unserem reporter paul ronzheimer wer
diesen krieg seit über zwei monaten
hautnah miterlebte paul kann man es
anders interpretieren als das der papst
tatsächlich die schuld an putins
angriffskriegs relativiert dem westen
eine mitschuld gibt
der papst gibt ganz offen der nato eine
mitschuld und er sorgt dafür dass er der
kreml propaganda der putin propaganda
hilft das muss man sich einmal
vorstellen werden die menschen
zusammengeschossen ermordet werden
hingerichtet werden sagt der papst naja
die nato ist auch irgendwie mit schuld
das ist ein einmaliger vorgang thomas
den man kaum fassen kann zumal der papst
zu beginn des krieges von vitali
klitschko wladimir klitschko nach kiew
eingeladen wurde als die gefahr groß war
als die stadt fast eingekesselt wurde da
hatte er zu viel angst hat sich nicht
mal geäußert und jetzt sagt er er will
zuerst zu platin putin fahren und bittet
um eine audienz das ist
unfassbar
putin nicht zu reizen ist ja eine
haltung die der papst nicht alleine
vertritt muss man sagen das war lange
auch offizielle politik auch in
deutschland sozusagen die
eindämmungspolitik
um das nicht zum schlimmsten kommen zu
lassen
man fragt sich was noch alles passieren
soll damit politiker oder der papst oder
wirtschaftsvertreter nennt nicht
verstehen dass es völlig egal ist ob wir
putin vermeint nicht provozieren er
macht genau das was er angekündigt hat
nämlich die ukraine anzugreifen und
dafür zu sorgen dass die das
existenzrecht der ukraine abzusprechen
das hat er angekündigt und das ist auch
so geblieben also ob wir jetzt dies oder
jenes sagen ist wladimir putin völlig
egal und auch der papst hat darauf
offenbar keinen einfluss
auf seine weise aus moskau heute auch
die nachricht dass man sich immer noch
nicht entschieden habe den papst zu
empfangen also eine demütigung
gleichzeitig noch mal nachdem er sich
dort ja geradezu angebiedert hat
zugleich auch die nachricht dass der
grill der patriarch der orthodoxe
orthodox russischen kirche jetzt auch
von den sanktionen der europäischen
union getroffen werden soll
gut das ist putins kirche der hat von
anfang an propaganda gemacht das ist so
wie es immer war aber dass der dort dass
der papst diese worte findet und damit
der campbell propaganda den
verschwörungstheoretikern all denjenigen
die zu beginn hatten versucht haben so
die ukraine anzugreifen ist nicht so auf
deren seite stellt das hätte ich nicht
für möglich gehalten wenn wir
gleichzeitig im bild sehen wir und du
spricht wie putin sich bekreuzigt wan
gang in die kirche ja da bleibt man die
worte stecken paule schauen wir auf die
aktuelle situation dort bei dir du bist
an der frontlinie unten im donbass wir
sprechen jeden tag und auch heute also
wieder die frage wie ist die situation
heute vor ort dort an der front
die russen machen langsame fortschritte
muss man ganz klar sagen ums lavignes
herum unter anderem
visionen auch in hf dagegen versucht die
russisch ukrainische armee
russland zurückzudrängen es ist ein
krieg der artillerie wo die russen
momentan die vorteile haben sie haben
mehr munition sie haben ein größerer
artillerie und einen minister seine
ukrainische minister sagte mir heute wir
sehen jetzt das ergebnis der verzögerten
waffenlieferungen also die tatsache dass
zu spät geliefert wurde und deswegen
sagt er wird es in den nächsten tagen
wochen es wird noch dauern aber sehr
sehr ernst bleiben bis dann hoffentlich
aus der ukrainischen sicht man auch
zurückschlagen kann ist kann man
momentan kaum weil dafür immer noch die
waffen fehlen im hintergrund hört man
bei dir ich weiß nicht sind das kinder
stimmen die man dort hört das heißt es
gibt auch so etwas wie einen in
anführungsstrichen alltag
ja die menschen hier in konstantinov
klar das ist sozusagen der ort von dem
wir immer aufbrechen an die front assist
so 20 kilometer entfernt die verhalten
sich relativ normal selbst wenn momentan
ist keine zu hören und was für eine
sirene ist sind sie draußen das wetter
ist besser geworden die menschen die
hier geblieben sind das sind nicht viele
aber die hier geblieben sind die
versuchen irgendwie ja mit ihrem alltag
weiter zu machen
euro uns an vielen dank paul